porque muchas personas abandonan el estudio,
o por falta de financiamiento,
o por distracción de los investigadores,
o porque mueren, y nadie continúa la investigación de campo.
Pero gracias a una combinación de suerte
y persistencia de varias generaciones de investigadores,
este estudio sobrevivió.
Unos 60 de los 724 hombres del principio
siguen con vida,
todavía participan en el estudio,
la mayoría tiene noventa y tantos.
Y ahora empezamos a estudiar
los más de 2000 hijos de estos hombres.
Y yo soy el cuarto director del estudio.
Desde 1938, hemos rastreado las vidas de dos grupos de hombres.
El primer grupo empezó el estudio
cuando eran estudiantes de segundo año en la Universidad de Harvard.
Todos terminaron la universidad durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
y luego la mayoría se fue a la guerra.
El segundo grupo que seguimos
era un grupo de chicos de los barrios más pobres de Boston,
chicos elegidos para el estudio
específicamente porque provenían de las familias con más problemas
y más desfavorecidas
en el Boston de los años 1930.
La mayoría vivía hacinada, sin agua corriente, sin agua caliente.
Cuando ingresaron al estudio,
se entrevistó a todos estos adolescentes.
Se les realizaron exámenes médicos.
Fuimos a sus hogares y entrevistamos a sus padres.
Y luego estos adolescentes se hicieron adultos
y cada uno hizo su vida.
Algunos fueron operarios de fábrica, abogados, albañiles, médicos,
uno fue presidente de EE.UU.
Algunos se hicieron alcohólicos. Unos pocos sufrieron esquizofrenia.
Algunos tuvieron ascenso social
desde la base hasta la cumbre,
y otros fueron en sentido contrario.
Los fundadores de este estudio
ni en sus fantasías más alocadas
hubieran imaginado que yo estaría hoy aquí, 75 años después,
contándoles que el estudio continúa.
Cada dos años, nuestro dedicado y paciente personal de investigación
llama a estos hombres y les pregunta si pueden enviarles
otra serie de preguntas sobre sus vidas.
Muchos de los hombres de Boston nos preguntan:
"¿Por qué quieren seguir estudiándome? Mi vida no es tan interesante".
Los hombres de Harvard nunca hacen esa pregunta.
(Risas)
Para obtener la imagen más clara de estas vidas,
no solo enviamos cuestionarios.
Los entrevistamos en sus salas de estar.
Conseguimos sus historias clínicas.
Les extraemos sangre, escaneamos sus cerebros,
hablamos con sus hijos.
Registramos en video las conversaciones con sus esposas sobre sus preocupaciones.
Y cuando, hace una década, finalmente les preguntamos a las esposas
si querían sumarse como miembros del estudio,
muchas mujeres dijeron: "Sabes, ya era hora".
(Risas)
¿Qué hemos aprendido?
¿Qué lecciones surgen de las decenas de miles de páginas
de información que generamos
sobre estas vidas?
Bueno, las lecciones no tienen que ver con riqueza, fama, ni con trabajar mucho.
El mensaje más claro de estos 75 años de estudio es este:
Las buenas relaciones nos hacen más felices y más saludables. Punto.
Hemos aprendido tres cosas sobre las relaciones.
La primera es que las conexiones sociales nos hacen bien,
y que la soledad mata.
Resulta que las personas con más vínculos sociales
con la familia, los amigos, la comunidad,
son más felices, más sanos y viven más
que las personas que tienen menos vínculos.
Y experimentar soledad resulta ser tóxico.
Las personas que están más aisladas de lo que quisieran de otras personas
encuentran que son menos felices,
son más susceptibles a recaídas de salud en la mediana edad,
sus funciones cerebrales decaen más precipitadamente
y viven menos que las personas que no están solas.
Y lo triste es que, en cualquier momento,
más de 1 de cada 5 estadounidenses informarán estar solos.
Y sabemos que podemos estar solos en la multitud
y podemos estar solos en un matrimonio,
por eso la segunda gran lección que aprendimos
es que no tiene que ver con la cantidad de amigos que tenemos,
tampoco tiene que ver con que estemos en una relación,
lo que importa es la calidad de las relaciones más cercanas.
Resulta que vivir en medio del conflicto es muy malo para la salud.
Los matrimonios muy conflictivos, por ejemplo, sin mucho afecto,
resultan ser muy malos para la salud, quizá peores que el divorcio.
Y vivir en medio de relaciones buenas y cálidas da protección.
Cuando nuestros hombres llegaron a sus ochenta y tantos,
quisimos analizar cómo fue su mediana edad
para ver si podíamos predecir
quién se convertiría en un octogenario feliz y saludable
y quién no.
Y cuando recolectamos todo lo que sabíamos de ellos
a sus 50 años,
no fueron los niveles de colesterol de la mediana edad
los que predijeron cómo envejecerían.
Fue el grado de satisfacción que tenían en sus relaciones.
Las personas más satisfechas en sus relaciones a los 50 años
fueron las más saludables a los 80 años.
Y bueno, las relaciones cercanas parecen amortiguar
algunos de los achaques de envejecer.
Nuestras hombres y mujeres que están en parejas felices
informaron, a sus ochenta y tantos,
que cuando sentían más dolor físico,
seguían de buen humor.
Pero las personas que estaban en relaciones no felices,
los días que informaban tener más dolor físico,
este se magnificaba por el dolor emocional.
Y la tercera gran lección que aprendimos sobre las relaciones y la salud
es que las buenas relaciones no solo protegen el cuerpo,
protegen el cerebro.
Resulta que estar en una relación de apego seguro
con otra persona a los 80 y tantos da protección,
las personas que están en relaciones
en las que sienten que pueden contar con la otra persona si lo necesitan,
los recuerdos de esas personas permanecen más nítidos más tiempo.
Y las personas en relaciones
en que sienten que no pueden contar con la otra persona,
son personas que pierden antes la memoria.
Pero las buenas relaciones pueden no ser armoniosas todo el tiempo.
Algunas de nuestras parejas octogenarias podían pelearse a veces
pero en tanto sintieran que podían contar con el otro
cuando la cosa se ponía difícil,
esas pelean no quedaban en sus recuerdos.
Pero este mensaje,
de que las relaciones buenas y estrechas son buenas para la salud y el bienestar,
esta sabiduría es vieja como el tiempo.
¿Por qué es tan difícil de entender y tan fácil de ignorar?
Bueno, somos humanos.
Nos gustaría una solución rápida,
algo que nos mejore la vida y que sea permanente.
Las relaciones son un lío, son complicadas,
y cuidar a la familia y a los amigos
no es atractivo ni glamuroso.
Dura toda la vida. Nunca termina.
En el estudio, las personas de 75 años más felices al jubilarse fueron las que
activamente reemplazaron compañeros de trabajo por nuevos compañeros de juego.
Como los encuestados de la generación del milenio,
muchos de nuestros hombres cuando eran adultos jóvenes
creían que la fama, la riqueza y lograr grandes cosas
era lo que necesitaban para tener una vida buena.
Pero con el tiempo, en estos 75 años, nuestro estudio ha demostrado
que les fue mejor a las personas que se inclinaron por las relaciones,
con la familia, con los amigos, con la comunidad.
¿Qué hay de ti?
Digamos que tienes 25, o 40, o 60.
¿Qué implica entregarse a las relaciones?
Bueno, las posibilidades son casi ilimitadas.
Podría ser tan simple como pasar más tiempo con personas que con pantallas
o amenizar una relación rancia haciendo algo nuevo juntos,
caminatas largas o citas nocturnas,
o acercarse a ese familiar que no hemos visto en años,
porque esas disputas familiares tan comunes
dejan una pérdida terrible
en las personas que guardan rencores.
Me gustaría cerrar con una cita de Mark Twain.
Hace más de un siglo,
él estaba analizando su vida,
y escribió esto:
"No hay tiempo, muy breve es la vida
para disputas, disculpas, animosidades, pedidos de cuenta.
Solo hay tiempo para amar,
y solo un instante, por así decirlo, para eso".
La buena vida se construye con buenas relaciones.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)